j'entendais des cours via écran
interposé depuis le 22 mars cette salle
implantée à monti le bretonneux a dû se
réinventer avec l'épisode du coït 19 les
plannings ont été adaptés les cours de
yoga pilates et de renforcement
musculaire se font par petits groupes
une situation inédite pour la structure
créée il ya dix ans j'ai mis des cours
le matin à l'heure du déjeuner des cours
le soir
j'envoie des liens pour chaque séance
les élèves n'en voit alors leur
programme de la semaine
et puis après chaque semaine moi je
définis le planning qui peut changer
toutes les semaines en fonction des
impératifs des uns et des autres et puis
j'ai en moyenne gérer entre cinq et dix
personnes par zoma chaque court et j'ai
une quinzaine de courts pour compléter
cette offre en ligne céline a décidé
depuis le 2 juin de donner la
possibilité à sa centaine d'élèves de
pratiquer des cours en extérieur au
programme aujourd'hui du pilates expiré
par la bouche décontracté votre gorge
vos épaules et vos bras inspiré par le
nez et tirez votre colonne vertébrale
comme si un film tiré par le sommet du
crâne
expirez bouche ouverts ça change que je
peux revoir les élèves que je peux avoir
plus de monde que si j'étais dans le
studio
parce qu'au studio avec les normes je
pourrais pas avoir plus de 4 ou 5
personnes et là je peux en avoir neuf
donc ça change beaucoup et puis ça
permet donc vraiment les revoir et
pouvoir bien les corriger des cours en
extérieur trois fois par semaine qui
séduisent les pratiquants c'est super je
trouve que c'est une très belle
expérience
ça apporte toute chose moi depuis le
début qu'elle en a proposé j'en ai pas
raté un seul au niveau du pilat ton
travail
le centre et ça change tous les repères
donc ça fait travailler différemment est
ce intéressant
les cours reprendront à l'intérieur le
lundi 22 juin mais vu le succès
rencontré avec ses cours en extérieur
ces lignes devrait continuer pendant la
période estivale